I think the White House and and the the
president's re-election need to take
this a bit more seriously hey guys I'm
off for August but the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC takes no time
off from their sheer and utter lunacy is
this going to harm the campaign more
personally because President Biden you
can't talk to him about this than it
does practically or do you think this is
pretty harmful to the campaign I think
that this is something that President
Biden is being talked to about the
question is is it a big group Roundtable
conversation I would argue to say no
um if you look at the ipsis poll right
after the plea deal that then fell apart
but the plea deal that was announced for
Hunter Biden the Americans who were
Poland who were asked they viewed this
as a personal issue for a hunter and not
a issue for President Biden and so right
now it is not actually affecting the way
that people are you know considering
voting in 2024. you know though Brandon
you can't help but watch all this play
out and it's like Donald Trump has been
trying to bring Biden's brand down to
him goes back to 2018 when he sent Rudy
Giuliani to Ukraine he's been desperate
and he did it yeah and and and and it's
Joe Biden's own attorney general that
just announced the investigation yeah I
mean it's basically politics trying to
turn your opponent strength into a
weakness and one of the things that I
think Joe Biden was elected to do was to
clear out the you know the mess in the
white house bring ethics and decency
back and this is clearly an effort to do
that now I think the White House and and
the the president's re-election need to
take this a bit more seriously than what
they're doing it was very easy for a
long time for Democrats to just say well
that's stuff on the crazy right house
Republican stuff right yeah and now if
it's going to be in trial it's going to
be Front Page News everywhere I think
they need to appreciate that this could
damage him pretty seriously